school administrator in Tennessee is on
the leave after a secret recording
revealed that he suggested sabotaging
plans to keep drinking water safe in
Nashville area schools our CBS affiliate
that's w tvf has reported on the
dangerous levels of lead in some of the
district schools for nearly a year now
in a new audio recording obtained by the
station Denis Neil the executive
director of the school's facilities
discusses not using water filters and
Warner's here with how the district is
responding and a good morning good
morning Gail Metro Nashville Public
Schools began voluntarily testing
drinking water in 2016 after the water
crisis in Flint Michigan around 30
schools then installed hydration
stations that filter out lead but a
secret recording now has parents worried
that their children's water is still not
safe it's just not acceptable
Shelly baldwin has two daughters in
Nashville's West End middle school she
said after testing showed high levels of
lead in their water some parents bought
water stations and filters they're
sitting in the school basement and there
was really no clear answer as to why
they weren't being installed but in a
secret recording obtained by CBS
affiliate W TV F Dennis Neal the
executive director of facilities for
Metro schools can be heard resisting use
of the filters
we can't we can't we cannot support it
in the recording Neil also responds to a
suggestion to break the lights that show
when the filters need to be changed we
got to figure out how what we're gonna
do with these hundred if we have it or
not and seven filter ones well that's
one thing stick but we need to also see
probably
well the district is deeply concerned
about what we heard on the recording
district spokeswoman Michelle Michaud
said while they don't condone what was
said on the recording the filling
stations are expensive she claims the
filters are less effective in filtering
out lower levels of lead it's a huge
cost to the district hundreds of
thousands of dollars
misho says the 37 locations that had
lead levels exceeding the EPA's
recommended 15 parts per billion have
been fixed but she does admit some
locations still have lead levels below
that number something the American
Academy of Pediatrics says is
unacceptable for children and parents
like Baldwin say more needs to be done
this is children's developing brains and
we cannot put money above their health
and wellness we reached out to Dennis
Neal but we did not hear back he's on
administrative leave pending an
investigation
misho told us the district is now
embarking on random water quality
testing and if it finds any more levels
that exceed the EPA recommendation it
will remediate them Nora this is just so
infuriating if you're a parent I mean
the evidence is so clear about what lead
does to your brain there's no point of
even going to school if you have lead
poisoning I mean you're gonna be ruined
for life and it's not after the problem
in Flint I'm trying to figure out why
they were resistant because of the cause
because it was inconvenient I don't get
it good question but props to Phil
Williams the investigative reporter at
station has done many national
award-winning stories there thank you
Anna
thank you